the jurgen experience like if you went
over a guy's house and he had a
a real doll you know one that doesn't
move
but you know he's like well i just
prefer that to masturbation you're like
oh
i don't know like masturbation is
normal but that's one step removed like
that's
weird that thing looks really real well
the thing about real dolls is that they
because they don't move i mean obviously
i went to the real doll factory because
they don't move and speak they're still
like a
fetish and it's a very niche thing you
have to be turned on by dolls
or you have to have an incredible
imagination where you can imagine them
coming to life
the thing about robots with artificial
intelligence and ai
is that you don't then they're not so
much of a niche and a fetish they are a
uh um similitude of a human being they
are they are trying to
um to be to be a replacement
relationship really
and with a robot it's much more about
the relationship than about the sex
because you can have sex with a doll
the whole point of a robot is that you
can have a relationship with it
yeah it's um the joaquim phoenix movie
she yeah that movie is that she or her
her
yeah um where he's has a
love relationship with this voice
essentially i mean that's what we're
talking about we're just talking about
in the physical form
but i'm i'm worried that this is
inevitable
i just it seems inevitable it seems like
if this
these companies are already developing
ones with wonky ai
it's going to be like the difference
between that brick
that michael douglas had on the beach
and uh you know a galaxy
s20 ultra you know the the newest latest
greatest
cell phones that they're just going to
get better and it's going down
it is totally inevitable they'll always
be quite expensive
but it is totally inevitable and there's
a there's a guy called dr david levy a
british guy who wrote a book in 2007
called love and sex with robots
where he predicted uh by 2050
uh human robot marriages would both be
legal and acceptable around the world
and i think he thinks that's going to
happen sooner now um but yeah i
i think this technology is inevitable it
doesn't exist so much at the moment
because at the moment you've got these
robots that
look very realistic because they're like
real dolls
and the ai isn't bad but they can't walk
walking is really really expensive
to develop and it drains a lot of power
so they haven't worked out how to do
that that's the kind of next frontier
so you haven't got this this science
fiction fantasy of like a robot that
will come and knock on your door and
deliver herself and say hello i'm your
new girlfriend or whatever it is
we're quite a way off of that but it is
going to happen
uh whether or not it'll be cheap enough
for everyone to have one
is is another matter but it's definitely
going to happen do you think that people
will propose
laws to prevent this like once it starts
seeming like it's inevitable once the
general public goes hey
wait a minute like this is not good and
then
people realize that their romantic
relationships like they're going to be
replaced
men and women and women too i mean women
are going to be tired of men's [ __ ]
you know i think that's probably true
but then i mean i can't speak for all
women here
um but i think certainly
my experience and and i don't think this
is a minority view
is that women find the idea of having
sex with something that you don't know
genuinely wants you
to be very unsexy indeed and it's much
harder like all of
those real dogs they make male realdolls
they're bought by gay men like women
it takes a it's very very difficult it's
not sexy to
to to have sex with something that that
isn't really into you
basically isn't that kind of the same
thing with playgirl
like playgirl the idea was well women
should have a magazine like playboy too
like okay
you know who buys it gay men exactly
is very very it's a very very different
thing but i do think there will be women
who want companions and so
forget about the sex there'll be women
having relationships certainly
with with very realistic male robots too
definitely um but in terms of whether or
not they're going to be laws against
this
there's a campaign against sex robots in
the uk that at first was trying to get
laws
banning sex robots or the development of
sex robots in the uk and now has kind of
softened their stance and says
they just want proper discussion ahead
of maybe making some laws
but the point is the cat is out of the
bag we could you know we could ban it in
the uk
people will be making them in korea or
in somewhere unless there's a kind of
global
decision not to do this and there are
too many rogue states for
for this not to happen so it is going to
happen um
and always you know the law is really
out of step with technology you know if
you look at things like revenge porn
something that we know instinctively is
so wrong it's been really hard to
criminalize because of the way that we
all live now everybody's taking pictures
everybody's selling them all the time
people can upload them and ruin
someone's
life in a moment and it you know the law
is kind of grinding on slowly trying to
keep up with all of this
and so for example in the uk that what's
illegal in terms of
sex dolls is if you you're not allowed
to import
um a child sex doll so it's the
importation of it that's illegal not
having one
but trying to get it into the country
just because the laws are kind of so old
and creaky
so i don't think actually it's something
that we can stop
with laws we can stop it by saying
actually i don't want this and i'm
prepared to accept
compromise in my relationships and i'm
prepared to accept that
in order for me to grow as a person i
need to be challenged and not constantly
in a relationship where all that matters
is what i want
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available
everywhere but after december 1st they
will only be available on spotify but
they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love bubba